une saison avec de grandes ambitions le
Vélo Club et l'encs Saint-Quentin en
Yveline présenté ce weekend sa type vous
sert composé de 16 fill dont 12 recrues
le collectif de National 2 pourrait bien
faire briller la France aux Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques cette année
B le niveau est bien parce qu'on a la
ralallemand qui a un niveau
international euh on a 4 jeunes filles
qui ont au niveau national et d'autres
niveau régional mais si ça peut bien se
passer je pense un sentiment que partage
le parrain de l'équipe et Champion du
Monde 2010 Quentin lafg ça a l'air
d'être une belle équipe en tout cas
beaucoup d'ambitions qui s'est staffé
qui a l'air de plus en plus
professionnel cette année l'année 1
commence avec beaucoup d'ambition dans
le collectif avec en tête d'affiche
voilà la RAL allemand qui a qui a montré
de belles choses au niveau national sur
les championnats de France piste et
cetera qui fera j'imagine un peu office
de leader qui va essayer de fédérer un
peu tout le monde pour aller chercher
des beaux résultats donc une belle
équipe un beau collectif et et voilà
Jeur souhaite tout le meilleur pour
cette année l'objectif de la saison
atteindre le top 5 du classement avec en
ligne de mirire la National 1 parmi les
leaders de l'équipe pour accéder au haut
niveau la versaillaise Lara l'allemand
tout juste 19 ans qui espère bien voir
prier l'équipe cette année moi je
connais l'équipe et je sais que tout va
bien se passer on espère déjà réussir à
monter plus haut que l'année dernière
avec les problèmes qu'on a eu mais je
pense performer déjà sur les Coupe de
France faire des places parce que c'est
dans les 20 premières qu'on peut avoir
des des points donc figurer dans les 20
première place dans les coupes de France
prochain rendez-vous la première épreuve
de Coupe de France le 24 mars en
Bretagne avec les boucles gegonaises et
pour les PISTAR d'un enjeu de taille à
172 jours des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques certaines ont encore des
chances de décrocher une place pour les
jeux un rendez-vous à domicile au
Vélodrome national de 50 ans en
IBL